thank you so much for doing this with me
today I loved the series just absent and
I think that you are pairing with Mark
it's just so good and I really there's
so much I want to get into but I
actually have a few other questions I
want to start with because you're known
the the the subject matter you tackle is
you know it it can be heavy it can be
deep and serious and I want to sort of
maybe throw a little I want to try to
get you to laugh a little bit or you got
it throw out some you know do a little
bit of other stuff so do you remember
your first movie or TV show crush my
first movie or TV show crush I mean dude
who was had to be the Six Million Dollar
Man or Lou Ferrigno or the Hulk man I
mean you know and but then I also
remember Daisy Duke I couldn't really
watch it and then of course Bo Derek
when I was a kid I could not I remember
watching like 10 would come on TV and
I'd be watching TV with my parents and
just the fact that her last name was
Derek I couldn't I
I just could not I couldn't move I was
frozen I was frozen under the Afghan
blanket on my my parents couch just so
embarrassed mortified Tess that she was
running down the beach in slow motion
and there's something about slow motion
when I was a kid like Six Million Dollar
Man running in slow motion and that
sound that nananananana minute that was
and her on the on the beach that's
reserved for informative memories on the
screen for me the other thing is of
course that I mean the other things you
were watching as a kid nothing at
slow-motion like that exactly I think
it's step printing slow motion a lot of
that I don't think that's in camera slow
motion I think that's a lot of that is
like Phil Solomon Dubrow a one of our
film school references rest in peace
Phil so and yeah a hundred percent with
that I was really shocked to hear that
he had passed on yes
is there a TV series that you would love
to guest write and direct for an app
pastor yeah like one episode of a TV
series
you know I an episode of the TV series
that I liked and guessed right and
direct I mean I'd have to go back to my
childhood again it would be Miami Vice
you know it I don't know about anything
that's happening now everyone every
every everything is in such control now
and you know I never thought about
making TV in a way that I would come on
and just do one piece and leave you know
I that's why this whole you know series
to me was you know I wrote directed
every episode and it was it was an
extension of the films I had been making
making and you know unified voice but
but I can see you know there's so many
great TV shows that that have multiple
voices adding to them I just don't
necessarily know how I would do that but
I'd say Miami Vice I'd like to come on
and that you know take the reins from
Michael Mann see if I can't be his
disciple what movie do you think you've
seen the most Creepshow George Romero
really that was the first movie when I
was uh maybe seven my brother turned
nine and on his ninth birthday my
parents rented a VCR you know this is
before we owned our own VCR and they
brought up they they brought a VCR home
for his slumber party and they had two
movies they had Creepshow and airplane
two and we sat down with all my
brother's friends and I was just a
little kid in the back and we watched
those movies and I just I was scared out
of my mind and I was blown away that I
was watching a movie at home so two
months later at my eighth birthday
whatever seventh eighth birthday I ran
into VCR had all my friends over for a
slumber party rented Creepshow and
airplane to about four months later
April comes around my family bought a
top loader VCR and we got a subscription
to HBO and what was on
Creepshow Creepshow and airplane two and
so I put in a tape on whatever the the
slowest mode the 6-hour mode 6-hour mode
of the tape and recorded those two
movies and literally my fourth-grade
year when I was in fourth grade I
watched creeks show every day after
school I brought a different friend home
every day after school and has at 3:30
in the afternoon watch Creepshow put in
the tape watch creeks show until I die
you know it's a 30 kids in my class
after 30 days I was all alone and I was
just addicted to that movie um you know
my fourth grade year just watched it
repeatedly have you ever thought about
doing like a horror movie oh yeah oh
yeah I mean in fact in I know this much
is true I got to exercise a little bit
in Episode four I got to exercise some
of this horror movie obsession that I
have inside me I mean a lot of my lot of
my work a lot of my you deals with fear
you know I'm as a writer I'm confronting
a lot of the things that scare me
psychologically emotionally in in terms
of like guilt of like what could happen
in a situation you know and this feeling
of responsibility and so you know as a
family member so I put all of that into
my movies and I'm making movies about
people but I have this this gene inside
of me that goes towards horror movies
and that as a as a as a kid and as a
young adolescent it was horror movies I
mean the second movie I pricing more
than anything is Evil Dead - Dead by
Dawn and you know those movies Texas
Chainsaw Massacre all of the other you
know Romero films Toby you know - tobe
Hooper movies you know and then the
Dario Argento films I just watched on
just repeat repeat repeat and then I
discovered Scorsese and and that changed
when I was like 15 16 I think Goodfellas
came out and I said that then all of a
sudden became my my Bible
and from that moment forward I pinned a
picture of Scorsese above my bed and
used to literally you know worship
Scorsese my whole rest of my adolescence
and that kind of filmmaking the Scorsese
opened the door to to everyone else for
me to you know - Cassavetes Charles
Burnett there's so many other filmmakers
that then I became obsessed with and but
I still have that horror movie and I do
have one that I that I'm writing you
know we'll see we'll see if I have the
courage to make it I was gonna say it
would be very interesting to take your
filmmaking style and bring it and have
the horror movie sort of in your space
rather than you going to the horror
movie space you know what I mean what is
I mean you say an episode of episode 4
of I know this much is true there's this
moment where he gets out of his hospital
bed and it's I mean that whole episode
to me is a bit of a horror movie but
yeah it's the thing with horror movies
is I always thought that they were
aesthetically you could do anything in
them right the the the play book was
wide open for a filmmaker making a
horror movie I mean look what Dario
Argento could do was sit em Raimi does
and people do I mean that's one of the
extreme cinematic experiences still I've
ever seen you know Evil Dead - Dead by
Dawn is only a movie there's no other
translation there's no book you could
read that would give you that same
experience it is it is it is hyper
highly cinematic and so that's what I
that's that's I think that was one of
the things that I loved about horror
movies and all of my stall of my films
that I made as a as like a teenager and
a high school student
we're always horror movies you know the
very first movie ever made was called
the bat movie and it was about a rubber
bat that attacks people and it's so
interesting because in another reality
your filmmaking path is so different it
is you know
it is talking about Phil Solomon I had a
I had a a movie that I wanted to do a
vampire movie in film school and I
brought film now I fill the idea and it
was gonna be a vampire movie called suck
and he I told it to him I went to his
office hours and he basically told me if
I made that I would embarrass myself and
I would embarrass the school and that I
and that as a filmmaker and as an artist
I had to get more serious about my my my
ideas and we sat down and I went to his
office every day and but learned from
Phil he taught me how to tap into what
this kind of the the surface of the
story that I was trying to tell was all
about and so I renamed that movie raw
footage and it was about capturing this
traumatic moment on on on a home video
camera and this kid who captures this
tragic moment of his family like the
Zapruder film or something that in that
affects his who he is as a as a as a
young man growing up and you know Phil
help me tap into that so I think it's
Phil Phil Solomon's responsibility he
steered me away from from my horror
roots yeah yeah I think that a lot of
people I think maybe don't know what
films go I think a lot of people
nowadays think that they can do and some
people can make movies without going to
film school and others go to film school
I think maybe you've that's one of the
examples of what you get out of a film
school is a mentor you know shaping you
when you're not a hundred percent where
to go sure absolutely absolutely I mean
every artists you know need mentors it's
yeah there's apprentices in every field
getting to be a you know car mechanic
you'd need to learn from someone there's
always a wizard I mean Luke Skywalker
had Yoda you know we we we all had need
someone and if we're lucky enough to
guide us some for some people that's our
parents you know that's you know another
figure in our life and I think that's
yeah it's crucial I mean Phil was
definitely a father to me of cinema we
make totally made totally different
movies I mean he made it
you know experimental avant-garde films
that dealt with memory and I think I was
really influenced by that Phil I talked
to our mutual friend Jim health and
quite often who you know has you know
I've met in film school has been editing
my work for 20-something years now and
you know we all talk about Phil is like
our Jiminy Cricket he's he's unconscious
he's on our shoulder and even though
Phil has passed away Phil still talks to
me he's he's he's like Wrath of Khan
he's warmed himself his his self inside
my prey in a beautiful way and anyway if
anyone has not seen Phil's movies I
think they're out there on Vimeo or
something but he made some beautiful
films a hundred percent
I remember watching any yeah I could go
on another another thing
okay so jumping into why I actually get
to talk to you today this is a project
that other filmmaker has been trying to
tackle since like the 90s I think
Jonathan Demi was looking at it well Jim
Sheridan um a few people were looking at
it and I think that I don't think this
move this material could actually work
as a two-hour film and be as effective
do you think that the you having six
episodes to tell this story is really
what was able to crack this material
yeah absolutely I mean if you just look
at the size of the book I mean when I
first met with mark back in 2015 he had
actually Wally lamb had been you know
who had wrote and written the book had
been involved in hi you know as this
author involved in Hollywood and all
these adaptations trying to get a made
for all these years and it's Gina Prince
Blythewood was involved too at one point
and she's such a great filmmaker and
they could have all done in two really
interesting things but I think that just
the the challenge that they probably
face was just scale you know it's just
too much how do you take that thousand
pages and
and boil it down to to its essence
you're gonna just lose so much and so
when Wally
you know after 18 years or something of
trying to get it made the rights
eventually reverted back to Wally and
you know I think he was probably in a
moment of that we all get to in this
business of like oh you know our dreams
of making something into a movie or
never gonna never gonna work out and his
agent said well let's start over
who would you in your perfect
imagination who would you see as these
characters as dominic and Tomas and
while he said Mark Ruffalo his agent
said well let me reach out to mark so
she reached out to mark and Mark said oh
I'd love to read it so he read while
he's booking a weekend and I guess he
called Wally and said I'm gonna get this
made and so then he's like I gotta find
a writer and director to make it so his
first call is to me and I met with him
and you know we just talked about the
scale of this thing and we were like
this is its you couldn't you can't make
this into a movie you know I know from
doing adaptations before you know how
hard it is to boil something down to
curate a book into into a piece of
cinema I also know from my movies like
place beyond the pines about my own
personal ambition and how I always want
to tell bigger and bigger stories right
and I'll place beyond the pines for
instance I had written that movie had
written an intermission in that movie
you know there's the moment where you
could ryan gosling story then you get
Bradley Cooper's story and then they
were supposed to be a title card that's
at intermission and you were gonna be
able to take a break go to the bathroom
get soda whatever you did and you come
back and then you watch the third part
with the kids but that wasn't realistic
in the marketplace and I'm not you know
I don't have the cachet of Quentin
Tarantino to be able to release the
movie with an intermission he's you know
right now so so I had to change that
intermission title to 15 years later and
I had to truncate that movie to be able
to fit inside 2 hour and 20 minutes and
I love the cinema as I know you do and I
love going to the movies
going to church you know it's a very
very sick it's a it's it's a sacred
place but unless you have a franchisable
universe it's hard to tell a more
expansive story I think movies now are
is like a perfect place to tell a story
like moonlight or something right or
like Brokeback Mountain you know or Blue
Valentine you know those are movies that
can be that can be that we're like you
know look at Brokeback Mountain was a 27
page short story that expanded perfectly
into a feature-length film because you
could expand from it so mark and I are
immediately talked about like we can't
we don't have enough runway we don't
have enough canvas in a movie theater to
do this so let's you know I've been
thinking a lot of years about doing
doing something long-form for for
television and I love the idea of being
able to live with characters for longer
and you know because I always felt like
the characters and my movies were like
my friends and I felt like for audience
members to they would be their friends
and so the idea of making this series
where you got to know somebody a person
people but mostly this character dominic
and got to really know him as intimately
as you could know like a best friend or
or a family member and that he would
enter your home every Sunday by hate for
an hour and you get to spend time with
him that he could actually be a living
breathing
tangible human being in in people's
lives and you know that's that's what
movies always meant so much to me the
characters and movies always felt like I
knew them you know it could be Travis
Bickle or it could be I don't could be
you could you know it could be anyone
that I felt like oh that's someone that
I knew that I that I understand and it's
like a real person that actually lives
in the world and so for this over the
course of six weeks I thought I could
create a real living breathing human
being and and you know you know I love
actors and performance so much and I
felt like this could be a perfect medium
for me to explore character and
performance and there could be moments
that I could fit inside a TV series that
I wouldn't necessarily have the
capability to do in a movie you know for
instance at the end of episode two
there's like a 20 page there's a 20
minute see I think it turned out to be
like 16 minutes in the actual show but a
16 minute scene inside this therapists
office now
that was a 20-page scene on this on the
script I there's no way I could ever
devote in one of my movies at least a
20-page scene to a movie because that's
like one sixth of the whole real estate
that's available but over six hours you
can deal with that dynamic and so I was
just I was just thrilled by this
opportunity to deal with to be in spaces
for longer periods of time to be with
characters for longer periods of time
and that maybe we could actually go on a
life life's journey with them and at the
end of the and I know it's you know I
know that the series is is can be
relentless and extreme at some times but
one thing that's happened in the last
couple of weeks after episodes six came
out is there is such a release in them
in the show you know there is such a
catharsis that this character goes
through that Dominic ghost if there's
actual a glimmer of a change that this
guy starts to have and it's really to me
it feels honest
earned and I mean I have to tell you I
had so many people from my life
from high school that because I'm not on
any social media but those people I
haven't talked to in 28 years that
reached out to me that said that they
watch the show every week and that they
changed their life and that you know I
was so touched by that because you know
I didn't know about releasing a show
during the middle of a pandemic what it
would do and there's its ability of like
everyone's isolated at home and here we
are with something heavy and people
wanted you know I knew that the journey
would lead somewhere but just the
response I had from people that from my
life that who came out of the woodwork
that felt like it changed them was was
kind of overwhelming to me so that was
kind of what it was all about to me it
was just yeah putting putting some real
people in real moments and a real life
on-screen really real well
I ended up watching the whole series
recently all very close together because
I am NOT I I didn't want to watch it
every week I wanted to watch it all
because I you like I heard you created
this as essentially a six something hour
movie and I was like well I want to
watch this as close as I can together
did you ever did you have a preference
about people watching it every week or
waiting to watch it all I thought it was
interesting what happened when people
watched it every week um I you know to
use a food in analogy I thought of it
it's like if you go to a diner and you
know not many people are gonna order an
entire blueberry pie when you order some
pie get a get a slice and if that slice
is good enough you're gonna come back to
that diner next week and get another
slice you know it's it's it can be a lot
to just sit down with a whole pie I mean
it can be gluttony so I was interested
in this idea and I tried to shape every
episode when I was writing it as its own
you know every episode has its own
identity every episode is about
different things every episode has its
own arc to it there is also I believe it
can work
and one fails you know one you know one
gluttonous I've been zing of the whole
show but yeah what was your response I
mean I think it can work either way like
it didn't me to say I one of the big
inspirations for this was also Bergman's
Fanny and Alexander which I never see
you know which was made for TV which I
never saw on TV is I wasn't in Sweden in
1980 or whatever it came out but I saw
it at the Film Forum a couple years ago
and the way the Film Forum released it
in their revival of it was uh they
showed part one and two and one day and
then you know the other some other parts
on another day and so I got to watch it
fit in in pieces and I thought I really
enjoyed like coming back to it it's also
something about dealing with a write
literature and film is so there are two
different formats but there's something
that a novel has write in it and it has
it has moments of reflection right you
can put down up a book and go to bed and
consider it and wake up in the morning
and then pick it up again and start
again you know there's this idea of the
chapters which allow you to reflect and
the the most successful example I can
think of in in movies of chapters being
used well is Lars von Trier breaking the
waves where he has those inner titles
those chapter breaks which allow you to
digest what you've seen and to reflect
upon what you've seen and to prepare
yourself for the new stuff so I thought
this idea of chapter breaks was a good
thing but I'd be interested from you so
you saw it you watched it all in one
fell swoop that's the thing I didn't I
just didn't want to watch it I'll just
tell you what I did and this is I try
not to put myself in who's like this but
I watched the first two episodes
back-to-back and then I did the next day
episode 3 short break
episode 4 and then the next day episode
5 the day after episode 6 so I didn't
talk
all back-to-back but I watch them all
very close together um and but that's
how I knew I wanted to do it I think
that the material is very heavy to sit
down for six and a half hours
and do it all although I could do it um
I just that's just the way I did it yeah
yeah that that sounds like it works I
mean look there's no right way or wrong
way to do it that that seems like it
reflects my experience with Bergman
which also can be you know heavy heavy
viewing but I do think when you're
dealing with heavy stuff sometimes those
moments of reflection are deck and being
can be important but I've heard from
friends now that have watched it that
that binge dydt and you know I think it
was intense
the problem with binging something
that's so intense is sometimes you could
become oversaturated you know with with
some feelings and I think there's no way
I don't know anyone who would ever sit
down and read a thousand-page book all
in one sitting
it's just it's a lot it's a lot - it's
it can be a lot to take in so I think
spaces is good and I think it's one of
the one of the you know I was excited to
sign this deal with HBO - because that
they were just you know on one hand just
so great to work with but I also really
love the programming model I love how
you know the dough I don't want to say
the old-school approach but I love how
things are unveiled week after week um
no brings me back to a nostalgic place
of my childhood of night not being able
to wait for that next Nightrider episode
to come out sure listen I love HBO I
think what you're saying though and
something I've noticed is I like going
to museums and I have found that I can't
spend eight hours at a museum because I
just lose I lose sight of the like the
brilliance in front of me you know I'm
just saturated too much with with the
paintings and the everything so for me
yeah you know a few hours and then I
need a palate cleaner and then I you
know
Gork palate cleanse what
yes you know yeah totally you go to one
wing you know you go visit the the
renaissance wing or something and then
you take a break take a timeout compact
freighter completely I also listen I
think there's I love that HBO does it
every week because there's something to
bingeing but I do like the ability to
talk about it throughout the week but um
look I got a ton of [ __ ] questions so
let's jump into some others go which is
um in the writing process you when did
you guys realize that when did you
realize you wanted it to be six episodes
was there ever talked of four or eight
or was it sort of like write it and then
let's see where we're at and we'll
figure out the episode count we pitched
him thirteen episodes but that was my
very broad strokes that was that was
almost my adaptation of the book chapter
four chapter in the book that was my
early breakdown of what if we were
filming the book would be an HBO came
back and they said can you do it in six
and I said
think and so I took about six months to
think about how I could do it in six and
and they told me they said look we love
the book but we want this to be yours
and I had a meeting with Wally and I
talked to Wally lamb and I talked to him
about it he said Derrick I love your
movies I trust you he was like the book
is the book it'll always be the book
make this yours and so I got permission
from HBO and I got permission from Wally
to make it my own thing so I spent that
six months imagining what a six hour
version of this would look like and you
know maybe then it was kind and I didn't
quite make six hours I got six hours and
20 minutes sure because that last
episodes a little long but I thought it
needed to be longer because the
resolution I didn't want the resolution
to be cheap you know I didn't want the
resolution to just be a nice bow that
tied itself together I wanted I wanted
to really have time to experience this
kind of glimmer of hope and if you look
at Wally's book and his ending of the
book and my ending of the show they're
they're they're different you know
there's there's a lot of resolution in
the last chapter of of Wally's book and
I felt like it was going to be too much
resolution too much of a bow that in a
book it would work because you'd spent
these months reading this book or
however fast or slow you can read but
and it would be fulfilling at the end of
the book but when you're watching a
linear movie happening in real time
there's too much resolution you know
Dominic becomes like a gazillionaire
because he's really related to Ralph's
drink with water and he gets all this
you know money from the casino and he
ends up adopting Joy's baby because she
died and had HIV and him and essa get
back together for sure and then he turns
his grandfather's
and to a battered women's shelter there
was so many things that were happening
at the end that I thought I didn't my
favorite I looked to my favorite movies
and thought about resolution in my
favorite movies and I looked at films
like five Easy Pieces which has to mean
one of the greatest endings or a very
similar film and tone Manchester by the
sea which ends on a glimmer right a
suggestion of change a suggestion of
where a movie can lead to and I'd you
know ended place beyond the pines in
Blue Valentine and in a similar way
where it's it's an open ending you know
you're it allows the audience to still
be a part of the story when they when
the credits roll and that the audience
can kind of project their own you know
at the end of I know this much is true
we're not sure if dominic and desta get
back together and I love the fact that
the audience can have they can project
their own hope into that relationship in
their own dreams and just reminds me of
what happens at the end of you know
those movies that I love so much they
look at the end of the thing if you want
to go back to horror movies John
Carpenter's The Thing they're just gonna
stay there until uh you know until the
fire burns out and you you can know
what's probably gonna happen to those
two guys and what's gonna happen to the
world when springtime comes and the
rescue parties come back and probably
that disease is gonna travel to the rest
of the world but that's none of that's
in the movie we as an audience we we
make up that in our imagination so I
think the audience's imagination in
cinema and in television is a very very
valuable tool an asset and as an
audience member before I was ever a
filmmaker I try to always remember what
it what the experience is of being in
our audiences like and and what I love
about being an audience completely I
think that's one of the reasons why the
series works so well for me is that
you're not that it isn't Holly rising
Hollywood izing if you will Dominic and
he's all of a sudden having these
dramatic revelations you know he
has gone through a lot and he's not
gonna have like you know an instant
change to anything you know he's he's
you know I mean but I want people to
watch you if not but I'm very curious so
yet you you really something at six
hours 20 minutes how long did you have
like a much longer first cut of all
these episodes or was it very tight to
what you actually released yeah it was
it was pretty tight you know I mean the
cuts would range anywhere from an hour
and 20 minutes to an hour and five
minutes our first cuts of every episode
just like my first scripts for every
episode where were around that same ya
know they were always 70 pages you know
65 to 80 pages something like that you
know and then I would you know I was
able to to condense or curate the
scripts and then in the editing we were
able you know it we edited this thing
very I was shocked that we got it done
honestly Steve because as you know with
Jim and Ron Petain who I work with all
the time and you know editing we are I
we're slow some people would say slow
other people would say Thoreau but I
shoot a lot of footage and on this I
shot two / 35 millimeter film stock and
we shot 600 hours and one of the things
that Jim what and Ron and I yeah we were
our motto on set was let's let's keep
Kodak in business when we crust when we
crossed a million feet the crew the
whole camera crew I left set that day
and I don't know if you've ever gotten a
pie in the face but I got seven pies in
the face from the camera crew and it
hurts to get a pie in the face and hey I
couldn't tell if it was love or
aggression but I was bleeding my you
know that because those though
aluminum Titans they actually can cut
you anyway so I was bleeding through the
cream anyway uh so we shot a lot of film
and one of the one of our my disciplines
in the editing room and Jim and Ron and
I have always done this as watch
everything because we believe in gold
and the discovery of gold as where as
we're editing and so we did we watched
you know I wrapped shooting after 115
days of shooting in October and we had
told you know HBO had wanted us to
deliver and have it this on air in April
and I sat down with the editing team and
we brought on some new editors we
brought on Malcom Jameson and Nico Lewin
and we had a great post / - great VFX
post team led by Eric Paz Corelli and we
were all in the in a home in this old
Victorian home in Fitness in Brooklyn
and I got you know I finished production
I got in with all the editors and I said
I don't think it's realistic that we're
gonna make our deadline but we have to
try so we have four weeks to get done
with episode 1 & 2 they had been working
and going through everything I was like
let's just let's see what it looks like
if it's no good we're not gonna release
it you know that if it doesn't work if
we're not there yet when I can release
it somehow miraculously I don't know how
it happened and I think it was because
we were so clear even then with those
six hundred hours there the cream or the
gold rose to the top that we we just we
made we made these decisions that were
just we didn't second-guess we didn't
get too precious with it we just moved
forward and made made decisions and
trusted the script and trusted the
performances that we got and when we sat
down and watched it we thought to
ourselves well let's see what other
people think of this and so we sent it
to HBO and to the producers and and I
remember my producer Greg Feinberg was
like holy [ __ ] we're gonna we might make
it yeah let's let's keep trying who
knows you know there was still you know
as as massive as this as the project
is in six and a half hours you know
there's like there's like a thousand
visual effects shots and them in the
show which people don't really notice
because we all you know we tried to make
ourselves invisible you know I think as
as as a storyteller for me the most you
know I told you about my my love of
performance for me
performance is is the main way that the
story is told it's just like in Blue
Valentine
the story is told through actors you
know the feelings are expressed through
performers I really do believe that
people watch movies to watch actors and
performances and so as a as a as a
creative force behind that as the coach
I tried to make everyone else all my
other you know play all my other coaches
you know the editors the cinematography
the visual effects the production design
I tried to have them all be invisible
and serve the performance and let the
performance be the thing that that
that's that shine through and so with
that you know with that kind of
methodology it just it just worked but
there was a lot of I guess still don't
know how we did it just everyone got on
the same page it was abused a beautiful
beautiful team I feel very very
fortunate well the other thing is that
you know look at the you want to keep
HBO and everyone who financed this thing
very happy because obviously this is
really tough material and they
championed it so if they wanted an apple
you gotta find a way to get it in April
if we weren't happy with it if it wasn't
working I think HBO would have been the
first to agree okay it needs more time
you know and I've been involved with
plenty of films place beyond the pines
the editing the place beyond the pines
know traditionally as a as a director
you get a 10-week director cut making a
movie after 10 weeks
I hadn't even watched all the footage of
place beyond the pines yet I didn't
actually show my first rough-cut of
place beyond the pines and for six
months I the financier is were on ice
for six months
and they showed up to a screening of
place beyond the pines and on the I was
a little late because I'd been working
all night and I'll never forget I walked
into the screening and on the screening
room with a slate that the
well-intentioned assistant had put on
that said place beyond the pines first
rough-cut total running time three hours
in 32 minutes and so here was my
financier who had waited for six months
they had never waited that long to see a
rough cut and now my rough cut was three
hours and 30 minutes and I was it had to
be a two hour and 20 minute film I think
they were all preparing to fire me but
when they saw it they realized what you
know they realized the potential of it I
guess and they stuck with me and let me
finish my process and so I think the
same thing would have with HBO they're
so artist friendly and so collaborative
they just kind of set out a goal for us
like can you can you make this can you
hit this bullseye for us and we were
just able to and I think it just goes
back to you know moving maybe Jim and
Ron and I when the addition of Malcolm
and Niko we just we just learned how to
had a run race better yeah I don't know
this explains a lot I was wondering when
I saw four names for editing I was like
for editors unlike or Derek and for
editors on this one like that's a lot of
editors and I'm like that makes a little
more sense
well I always look at you know sheep
there's always one of my is one of my
main inspirations we talked about that
advice earlier but he was a really a
huge inspiration for this show mostly in
the use of it when I when it came to the
twinning aspect of the show because I
was really inspired by that scene in
heat where De Niro and Pacino meet up in
that diner in the middle of the night
and I was always blown away by that
scene because you never see their faces
on screens you get these two titans of
acting but their faces are never share
the screen it's always shot counter shot
and I thought like let's flip sides of a
coin and you can
you can never see both spaces of a coin
at the same time and I thought to myself
well that's how I'm gonna make this
movie - it's gonna be just flipped sides
of a coin and I'm not gonna have to
resort to all the technical trickery of
twinning eventually I adapted that and
changed it but anyway heat there's an I
think there's five editors on heat so
there's a way to edit and get a lot of
rooms going and and still maintain a
vision and you know and I you know
there's an editor I'm always in the
editing room - I always have my own
machine set up and so most most all the
cuts come through my room at the end and
I'm able to unify everything and see
every cut and yeah anyway I think a lot
of people don't realize what it actually
takes to put everything together but I
want to go backwards was there
discussion about shooting digitally at
all or was it were you always this has
to be film and when you're shooting that
much footage that that has to be a cost
that's not cheap to shoot that much
filming no wasn't you know it was a
discussion and it's always a discussion
to shoot and and the assumption more
often than not these days is that people
shoot digital and I have a little bit of
an issue with that being an assumption
because I love digital I've shot plenty
of things digitally Blue Valentine I
shot half of that movie on a red camera
but that format was a choice I used you
know I believe in using the digital
format to as a tool to better tell your
story or better express the story that
you're telling and I think it's a choice
now all these years ago like I heard I
don't the you know people would come out
and declare film is dead and I you know
I that always just rubbed me so the
wrong way because film it
is irreplaceable and I'm not saying it's
the only format like I said I love
digital but for this you know this this
story takes place in the 90s in the 80s
70s 60s 50s 40s 30 2010 right pretty
much the whole 20th century and in none
of those decades and none of those
errors was there at HD you know if I was
to shoot on a format of those of any of
those eras it would have to be for the
90s some kind of SD video some standard
def video and you know when I shot the
70s it wouldn't have to be like whatever
William Eggleston shot stranded in
Campton on and what would end up
happening for me is I'd have to choose
different formats to illustrate the
different times when film was a constant
throughout all those throughout all that
time you know film was around for the
entire 20th century and so I thought
film was a way to unify all of our time
frames I didn't want to differentiate
between the time frames I didn't want to
have anything except the production
design change in these time frames
because of a lot of it is about history
and memory and a place you know and you
gave to see you know this home that
Dominic it grew up in you get to see his
grandfather actually building that home
and so I didn't want that to be that far
removed because it was only 30 years
before Dominic was born that he was
building that half that house and so I
wanted to unify and I thought that film
could really unify it and you know HP
and beyond that also as a filmmaker I
believe in the power of film creating an
urgency onset there's something with
digital depending on what camera you use
but you can shoot and shoot and shoot
and shoot on digital whereas on film you
have a magazine which can be a different
length sometimes we'd shoot a
thousand-foot mag which would give us a
20 22 minute and sometimes we shoot on a
400-foot mag which would give us a nine
minute load and depending on those
those loads it gives it it creates like
a shot clock and so as a as a director I
think I usually I use a lot of sports
analogies I think of myself as the coach
my players are the actors and so if I
have a nine minute shot clock and I have
my actors come into a scene they know
they got nine minutes on the clock
to get something done to get some points
done and to me it just it it it it
raises the angst on set it it's like a
stick of dynamite to me film is like
dynamite
you light the fuse and you got this much
time and you know the fuses is almost
out it's almost out you better get
something before oh it's over okay you
know and undid all the you know I should
do well do valentine I shot digital I
wish shooting like 45-minute takes in
fact and there's there's not as much
urgency on digital in fact one moment
Ryan Gosling actually fell asleep during
a dinner scene in Blue Valentine for
real I got footage of him falling asleep
because digital can find that I think
digital can find the erosion of moments
in a beautiful way film could find a
spark and so no I brought it to HBO
there was a cost issue HBO was a little
bit on the fence about it you know they
they would have rather initially that I
shot digital and I said well let me just
shoot a test for you and so we shot a
test we got we got an Alexa and we got
the air and two / 35 and we put the
cameras right next to each other and we
shot the same test with both cameras and
we tried to make both cameras look the
best they could
right and we made a split screen and we
made this this this this is real to show
HBO and just said pick which one you
like better and it was unanimous for at
least for the story I was telling I'm
not saying for everything but for the
story I was telling film was clearly on
mildly the winner I will say one thing
that happened there was one thing I
realized on digital and and film was I
was shooting my friend Gabe Fazio who
was Mark Ruffalo's acting partner you
know in all the turning scenes and I was
do shooting this test on film and on
digital of him and he was leaning up
against a bridge and on film it was the
shot of this guy leaning up against a
bridge and I'm digital ice noticed that
there was an army of about 10,000 ants
crawling on the the the the architecture
of the bridge and walking towards Gabe
and sometimes digital can see too much
and that's great I realized that that
that could be a really interesting tool
for something but I didn't want people
to watch the show and be looking at the
ants
I wanted him to be in more of this
painterly world no no completely I've
actually I've recently watched some
stuff in IMAX laser projection and I was
sitting next to the director and after
the screening ended he I do a screening
series in LA we showed something that
was a number of years ago I came out ten
years ago and he said that's the
clearest I've ever seen the movie like
as in you you might make different
choices if you know it's gonna be that
clear yeah sometimes again when we start
talking about the imagination of the
audience to see everything can strip
something of its mystery I think it can
lose a little bit of the mystery and I
and what I love about filmmaking is that
mystery and this idea of the persistence
of vision and when you're watching a
movie or a TV show shot on film you know
you have this magical shutter so you're
seeing 24 frames a second but you're
also seeing 24 frames black per second
your brain chooses not to see those
right the the flicker of the shutter
and but it's still that's that's it
activates your brain in a different way
and there's just something about 24
frames a second film shudder shudder
degree it you know shutter angles that
that does something to our subconscious
and I wanted to tap into that completely
I wanted I want to touch on Episode five
specifically if you don't mind can you
can you actually say sure yeah yeah
that's okay I just put on the speaker
yeah you got me uh yeah the earbuds
dying damn out they are yes I want to
specifically talk about episode five
because it was I haven't read the book
and so when that episode happened and
you go back in time I was a not
expecting it and B it was so well done
um but that's also you're making
something like that on a budget so how
did you pull off that transporting
backwards in time to everything you did
in that episode yeah that was a very
important element of the story for me as
you know in my past work I've been
dealing with this idea of legacy a lot
and familial trauma and the things that
get passed on throughout the generations
you know that's what place beyond the
pines was all about and I was you know I
have an Italian American heritage and it
seemed like every italian-american movie
that I had seen dealt with like the
Mafia you know or wiseguys in some way
you know some of my favorite movies
Goodfellas Godfather you know it's all
mafia tell you but growing up Italian I
didn't that wasn't true to my life and
all you know my wife who has Italian
heritage that wasn't true to her life
and Mark Ruffalo is Italian American
heritage that wasn't true to his life he
was we didn't grow up with gangsters we
grew up an Italian American households
and we grew up with something Morse
a more specific version of this kind of
training of masculinity within that
culture and it was something that we
know for mark and I we carried with us
into our adulthood and we were really I
don't know
confronting it right as men this I do
this masculine upbringing this masculine
training as italian-americans that we
had and so I'm just I was always
fascinated with going back in time and
kind of uncovering my own family history
and I had a great-grandfather that moved
over to the states from from northern
Italy and in the 20s and this guy was a
very dastardly character it's only a few
stories I know about him but those
stories are so dramatic that they they
they they hung over my whole my whole
upbringing
they hung over my my grandfather's life
they hung low from my father's life hung
over my life and now I have two boys of
my own and I know that that guy that
great-grandfather made these choices
that are still very very much alive and
in my world and so I've always wanted to
go back in time and uncover those those
those choices that he made and this idea
of this trauma that could carry down
through generations and you know when
when you asked the question about could
this ever have been a movie that's the
first thing that would have been cut
from a movie version in fact you know
the first time I ever read this book
because I'm a I have I have struggles
with reading the first time I ever read
the book was actually a book on tape and
the book on tape that I listened to
didn't even have the Italian section in
it they just they cut it out um it would
be the first thing that people would
want to cut out but to me it seemed to
be one of the most interesting parts of
this characters kind of search for
homeless in himself is to kind of break
the cycle of you know it's it's
recognized as a curse in the story but
what that really is is it's family
trauma that that's passed on through the
generations and so you know so to
execute that the first thing I had to do
is find actors you know who felt like
they were from another time and I did
had no idea who I was gonna cast in that
role and then I saw Matteo Garrone dog
man with March elefante sure and Marc
marchello is truly from another time he
grew up in Calabria he's one of nine
children he is he's he's from the past
you know he's he's he's particularly
modern in a lot of ways but his face his
thoughts he is he is it he is he's a
visa he's a treasure and a relic and
I've never met anyone like him and when
I saw him on screen I went to reached
out to him he happened to be in New York
I met up with him he doesn't spit speak
a lick of English and when I met him I
immediately said that's that's grandpa
you know but it's against type 2 because
marchello is hilarious a comedian I mean
he's like the heir to Roberto Benigni
he's a he's a clown and here I was
writing this character this dastardly
grandfather this evil man who
traumatized his family for generations
with the choices he made and and here
was this sweet guy marchello and it's it
speaks a lot to his the power can his
power as an actor to be able to deliver
that performance and then you know in
terms of our production designed you
know then there was all these other
great actors that I found Burt oregano
Simoni co Coco Arena mascara so many
great Italian Americans you know I went
over to
and cast all the Italians there and you
know HBO brought them all to America and
we you know because it was important to
me that these were people that were not
Americanized right they weren't
necessarily Americans already they were
Italians because this is about the
immigrant story and so they had to be
first and foremost Italians and and we
tried to you know my last film light
between oceans was a period piece and
there was one thing about the period
piece that always was struggle to me
because I'm always trying to find the
imperfect picture the dirty picture you
know like the the imperfect family photo
and when you go back to research you
know so many um you know period photos
everything feels like a BBC drama not to
throw shade on that but everything feels
so clean and put together and I want to
define the dust and the dirt and the
sweat and you know one of the things I
talked about with my production designer
and costume designer um you know Kasia
and the in ball was that in all of our
old photographs there was no one had any
facial hair and I thought to myself well
I want to make a movie about the primal
human experience and these people should
be you know they're they're they're
almost like the cavemen version of our
of our characters later on and the
primal versions of our of this
italian-american upbringing and so we
just tried to make it as raw and as
dirty
and as sweaty I mean in fact we were
shooting one scene when you know
Domenico goes and gets his Brides at the
cousins house and we were shooting that
in the middle of the summer and we had
air conditioning in there for the crew
to keep everyone sane and I was just
like there was no air conditioning in
1915 when this scene is happening we
have to kill the air conditioning
everyone there is like I'm gonna [ __ ]
kill Derek
they were they were they were they hated
my cuts but everyone was the actors were
so sweaty for real and uncomfortable and
uh raw and as a crew we were too and I'm
like um yeah when I make things I'm very
much like I'm people have called me a
method director I believe in experience
and you know the crew they might have
been mad at me at that moment but I
think they all look back at that moment
as as one of the great times sometimes
hard moments that you go through become
like the greatest stories that you tell
but that was the kind of authenticity I
guess that we were going for is you know
let's go back in time if we're gonna be
back in time there's no air conditioning
back in time let's let's let's live it
as closely as we can and then I was
lucky enough to have actors who were
just so onboard with that and would
settle for nothing less honestly if I
was to try to you know marchello is so
hardcore that if I was trying if I would
try to Hollywood eyes it for him
he would he would have rejected me and
lost all respect for me so I had to I
had to I had to provide him of a true
experience I'm curious when you're
writing how are you thinking about the
visual style of how you want to tell the
story how early on are you thinking goes
with this project you work with a lot of
close-ups there's a lot of close-ups and
I loved it but I'm just curious when did
you know that's how you wanted to tell
the story using close-ups are you
thinking about that in the writing
process or is it when you're you know
when the script is done I'm addicted to
close-ups first off all of my films are
pretty much consumed with close-up suit
because I just feel like I can't get
when I'm in a room with actors and
things are happening I just want to be
in there with them I just want to be
yeah I read one time that John Ford said
that the most interesting landscape is
that of the human face and you know and
I try to balance my close-ups with some
extreme wide shots to to just give you a
sense of of environment you know and
Sergio Leone is like one of the great
examples of you
of this kind of visual dynamic of close
to extreme wide and all I've always
tried to live in that space I'm not much
of one for being in a medium shot when I
see a medium shot I don't know it just
looks a little bit I don't know I don't
know I guess it feels regular to me or
something and I don't know I part of my
whole a deal with with performances I
want to I want to put people under a
microscope I want to put actors under a
microscope and so when I'm writing I
watched the movie in my head every day
this was one of the disciplines I
learned when I was trying to make blue
Ballantine for 12 years right 12 years
I'm right Blue Valentine in the daytime
and I'm the night and I think to myself
I'm gonna be shooting this movie in
three months three months would come up
and I wouldn't be shooting the movie and
so I started to to discipline myself
with just watching the movie in the
screen of my mind so every day of those
12 years making blue Ballantine I
started to watch the movie and it's just
become part of the process of me making
films is when I'm writing when I'm in
pre-production I visualize the story and
I try to meditate or whatever you want
to say and go sit in a room and and just
you know I could be eating dinner with
my family and they could be saying to me
where are you right now and I'm just
watching the movie you know it's hat
it's happening and I could be driving
the car on the highway some you know 75
miles an hour and be thinking about the
movie which sounds dangerous but that's
I just that's just working my mind those
now I although I don't necessarily love
storyboarding now I storyboard some
things there's been plenty of
commercials that I've storyboarded
there's sometimes action scenes that you
have to storyboard and really plan out
you know the moments when Dominic and
Comus run across the road you know that
has to be like planned out you know to
the millisecond you know what happens in
those scenes but for the most part I try
to go on
after having visualized this thing and
seeing it so clearly in my head I try to
go to unset with as wide open as I
possibly can and open to discovery and I
try to tell my actors to surprise me
that's what I want yeah you know I live
with the script and with the movie for
so long on my own
once I get other people around me I want
them to show me their interpretation of
it you know I'm so I'm fascinated with
actors so one of those things that I do
with the close-up is I try to put the
camera away from the actors so they can
have some so they don't so they forget
about the camera
I think Ryan Gosling one time said to an
interviewer he said most movies you have
to pretend that you're you have to
pretend that it's real and he said on my
movies he has to always remind himself
that it's just a movie so I try to put
the camera in a place where it's not
going to be obtrusive with the actors
but it's just like a loving friend
that's in the room observing and
witnessing and experiencing with with
the actors and then from that place that
I find the camera I I'm just addicted to
going longer on the lens and to
experience and experience this world
from this kind of disembodied point of
view I guess it is and you know you
could talk to my DP Jodi Lee likes uh
you know on set he would sometimes force
me into doing a wide shot and every time
he did I was very thankful for it but
it's just the way I see the world if you
know if you and me were in a real room
and not on a zoom meeting right now I
would be my eyes would be it close-up on
you it's just the way I see things it's
just that you know I'm kind of consumed
with details and in people's the things
that aren't said you know in
conversations the moments between
moments I'm kind of obsessed with trying
to be inside the soul and the psyche of
a person and I just think the close-up
helps me helps me get there
sure what about I've spoken bunch of
filmmakers and sometimes they have you
know obviously multiple cameras shooting
a scene and then later I talked to Roger
Deakins and he talks about how it's just
one camera on set no matter what movie
he's making Blade Runner you name it
it's just one camera where he places it
so how often are you doing having
multiple cameras in a scene or is it
just usually one camera at all times you
know it depends on the scene and it
depends on the the project the film that
I'm making now there's certain you know
I've shot you know for instance blue
Ballantine the story of Michelle and
Ryan falling in love was all shot with
one camera and held one lens one point
of view
the second part of that movie the part
of them falling out of love was about
individuals
it wasn't about this union of two people
coming as one into one camera it was
about these people being separated in
their space with two cameras and so two
camera I shot that with two cameras
cross coverage and that became very
informative and important and
aesthetically it it allowed me to
separate them in the space and so I he
did utilize a lot of two camera coverage
in this show because I was shooting so
much improvisation right and you know
when I hear that web Deacon's it makes
sense because Deakins feels very very
controlled right and one thing I'm
trying to do as a filmmaker is balance
control with chaos right and so if I
have Rosie O'Donnell and Mark Ruffalo in
a scene together and they're too
heavyweight champs right and Rosie is a
really hard person to fight with right
because she's fought with a lot of
people she's she's had a lot of battles
in her life right and she knew that
character of Lisa Scheffer because she
had a social worker that was very
important to her and her upbringing and
she has five kids and she's just been in
that place she knows that that story in
that character and I and she's a
comedian and she's quick on her feet
so I can go into that room
and if I have a camera on Rosie and a
camera on mark I can get them to explode
my script and to find these discoveries
that could only happen one time and if
you're shooting this kind of diet these
kind of dialogue scenes with one camera
and I've done it plenty of times in my
life you have to you have to kind of
build it again in the Edit because you
try to rebuild these fleeting moments
and so if I shoot a scene with Rosie and
Mark you know that's a ten minute scene
and I shoot for four hours with them and
I had one camera I got four hours on
mark I got to go another four hours to
get Rosie side and some of those little
what I call them is like Halley's Comet
moments the moments that pass by the
screen and are so rare and precious that
they it takes another 80 years to get
them again sure if I have two cameras I
can catch Halley's Comet at the same
time I can catch both sides of it I can
catch because part of what I do is the
director is I really work with through
actors write a lot of my direction if I
want something out of Mark Ruffalo
I don't always tell him what I want
sometimes I tell Rosie what I want
so when Mark is coming into her office
and demanding that Thomas sees a doctor
and gets tested for HIV and he's being
really harsh with her um
I sense to myself this is imbalanced I
saw I'll tell Rosie are you gonna let
him talk to you like that this is this
is your office right and and that's all
I said all that Rosie needs and then she
comes back and fights and attacks him
and so I I work that way with actors but
I'd sometimes I need those two cameras
to to get those moments because you
can't you know the first time that she
will unleash that her and like the first
time that she comes in and like
surprises him was like hey wait a minute
I'm not a I'm not a gal okay a gal is
what you call someone's horse there's
there's only one true reaction that I'm
gonna get to that right the rest of it
is gonna be acting right or performance
but Marc's reaction to rosy saying that
the first time is going to be behavior
and so what I try to capture with my
camera is behavior and so two cameras
sometimes can be very very very helpful
with that Marc had to put on some weight
you've got all the stuff with him then
he has to put on weight you got you
coming back and filming when you're
carrying that much extra weight I would
imagine a lot of people get in a bad
mood because they're not feeling as good
because you literally are putting a lot
more pressure on your body did you
notice any sort of change with Marc once
you put on that weight that yeah you
know but it was the opposite because
here's the thing again this goes to this
goes to behavior when what I started
when Marc and I first talked about these
characters I said if I don't want to I
don't want to be embroiled in a
technical movie right if we're gonna do
this it has to end and you're gonna play
twins let's think about it when you're
born when these two twins are born they
look exactly the same they're identical
twins but they have 40 years of
different life experience 40 years of
choices and of consequence to their
actions so when we meet up with them
they're gonna look different and Thomas
is on these antipsychotic drugs and the
people that I know who have gone through
that have put on weight they put on
water weight with the medication so
Thomas at the very least is gonna be
heavier than Dominic and so Marc agreed
to do to do this process and so we
decided that the best way to do it was
to have him as Dominic to lose weight so
he lost like 20 pounds to play Dominic
and you know he showed he was he was on
like a strict like thousand or like 1100
calorie diet a day sure and so he was
you know the expression hangry he was
angry all the time and that added to
Dominic's angst right that added to this
kind of alpha male just uncomfortable
quality that he
and and it was from day one it was he
was on with that you know so that so the
physical thing changed his performance
and then one other thing I started to do
with him onset was I started to ask him
to do push-ups
and he it marks a good guy so he just
goes along with it but after you know I
was doing like a phone call scene with
him and Juliette Lewis and it wasn't
really happening and so I just said can
do 50 pushups so he dropped to the
ground 250 push-ups he came up he did
the scene and it was it it was actually
the cut that made it in the movie um he
was like a little out of breath and and
he smoking cigarettes and his chest was
kind of puffed out and um and I thought
it was so fascinating that it it it
tuned him in to this Dominic character
who's kind of desperate for breath you
know the traditional male with like the
big pectoral muscles he was and so that
became our go-to for Dominic like
anytime I needed to get mark in the
pocket with Dominic I'd have him do
push-ups and there was times when he was
doing four or five hundred push-ups a
day because it was just like you know do
another 50 and he he questioned it at
the beginning but eventually you know if
he wasn't getting the scene he would be
like maybe I should do push-ups and I
said yeah it was it was the instant way
for him to get into Dominic now at the
end of those like 16 weeks that we shot
with him is Dominic he was ready to go
off and be calmness and we had a lot of
stuff to still shoot you know we had six
weeks of shooting we had to shoot the
kids better shoot the teenagers and we
had a shoot grandpa's story and so mark
went off and he was excited that he
could go finally you know like a bowl of
pasta or have a doughnut but that lost
its luster like after the second day he
became so miserable
because because his body just wasn't
used to all this calories you know he
went from eating a thousand calories a
day to like 4500 calories a day and um
you know he eventually got to the point
where he was like he could only sleep if
he was
up in a chair so he was calling me in
and basically saying I don't know D if I
can do this
why don't I just put on like a fat suit
or something to play Thomas and and I
just encouraged him to stay with it I
said look as much as Dominic's weight
loss and hang greenness and you know
push-ups added to that character Thomas
is gonna feel a different way and again
I'm interested in your behavior not your
performance as much
and sure enough Marc showed up on set as
Thomas and he was like over 30 pounds
heavier and he you know we had gotten
the scene all set up and we were ready
to shoot and he wouldn't come out of his
trailer and you know the in which is
totally unlike Mark Ruffalo to do like a
diva move like that and so I went back
to his trailer you know I've had to
rescue plenty of actors from their
trailer in my time but never mark and I
met you know knock on his door and he
was the guy who I saw in that room
couldn't have been further from Dominic
he was vulnerable he was soft he was
scared out of his mind he was insecure
he didn't have any confidence he didn't
know if he could do it I spent about an
hour with him we watched the devil and
Daniel Johnston I eventually brought him
out to set and I've never forget that
moment
walking with mark on set as he like
shuffled behind me and feeling the AH
and the gasp from the crew as he arrived
on set no one knew who he was we all
everyone on the crew thought mark was
Dominic because he's so Method he was
like Dominic all the time and now he
shows up as this other guy Thomas and
you know no one could look at him and he
sat down in the seat and we were started
to shoot this the second side of the
scene and it was you know before we
started to shoot it was actually on
September 11 2009 teen that we shot
first they were Thomas and he sat down
and seen in the scene and my assistant
director said let's do a prayer you know
moment of silence for September 11th and
so we all did there's a moment of
silence and after about a minute we
heard this voice and it was mark as
Thomas saying a prayer for America and
it was just so
poignant and kind of haunting because
here we were telling the story that took
place in the early 90s about a guy who
tried to end the wars in the Middle East
by sacrificing his own by sacrificing
himself and here we were 40 years later
still with the reverberation of
everything that happened on September
11th which was a reverberation of
everything that happened in night in the
90s in in the Middle East and here we
had this guy who who all of a sudden
wasn't you are the crazy character he
was the Prophet to us he was he was the
truth and so we all decided we that
Thomas wasn't the person we were gonna
look at as as like a syndrome or a
sickness that he was just a man and
anyway you know it's that's that's kind
of the alchemy that I'm really
interested in as a filmmaker is what
happens when you start mixing these
different elements together what effect
do they have and I could go into a pitch
meeting with HBO and tell them what the
movie is gonna be and they could buy it
but then I start this process and
there's this alchemy that happens and
something happens that none of us have
expected and it takes on its own life
and that's my favorite part about being
a filmmaker is to is to be a part of
that alchemy sure the the actor I want
to make sure I get the name right I
think his name's Philip Ettinger yeah
the one who plays the the college
student version of Dominic and Thomas um
he did a phenomenal job as well yeah
he's amazing amazing actor I felt like I
was working with James Dean reincarnate
I was really blown away by his work so
I'm curious if you talked about how you
found him and just and working with him
to do those scenes yeah my good friend
Braden King a filmmaker had shot a movie
called the evening hour with Phil and I
had never heard of Phil before and then
one day I was watching
first reformed paul schrader and phil
has this one scene in that movie really
and it was the greatest performance i'd
seen in a decade you know in that one
scene and I called it Braden I was like
is that the guy you work with
and cratons it yeah and I was like dude
now I know why you picked him because
this guy's the greatest actor of all
time
and so I set up to meet with him and you
know we met at a had a pie shop in
Brooklyn and Phil told me that Mark
Ruffalo was always his favorite actor
and that he had met him backstage and he
marked as one of the reasons that Phil
became an actor and that people his
whole life had always told him that he
was kind of like Mark like a young Mark
Ruffalo and Phil also and he's talked
about this that's why I feel comfortable
talking about it hadn't had an older
brother that suffered his schizophrenia
and so he knew he hadn't this experience
that he could really draw from and play
again part of what I do is in casting is
try to cast actors that
can be the experts right of their own
experience and that they can create
these characters that are part them and
part the character that I've written and
so there's a little bit of a documentary
aspect to it and so Phil and I talked a
lot about his experience of being the
brother of someone who was dealing with
that and and also is a observations of
his brother and you know his brother
ultimately like we shot with him he was
like an extra in a scene he was great
helpful guy the whole time and um and
he's doing he's doing pretty well right
now and and and so Phil just was brave
enough to draw on his own personal
experience with that character and he
really he was you know we shot he was
our first sighting of Thomas Phil was
because Mark hadn't shot Thomas yet we
had shot all the 16 weeks with Marcus
dominic and then mark went away
and here comes Phil and Phil had been
studying what Mark had done as Dominic
had given him a bunch of dailies and
he'd been studying Mark's Dominic but we
still hadn't seen Thomas yet and so Phil
came out with a brand new Thomas that we
that none of us knew how Thomas was
gonna be but Phil showed us mark I
started as I was shooting Phil I started
sending mark Phil's performance of
Thomas and mark started studying what
Phil did as Thomas to inform his version
of Thomas so it was it was such a
beautiful collaboration that way and
everyone all the actors were so expect
'full and it's just a gift you know of
each other and anyway yeah Phil he is
he's a real treasure like I said I
really did feel like I was working with
a modern James Dean yeah I think that
one of the things that the that your
film or series does so well is the
progression of watching Thomas the
progression of what happens to them you
know it's not just this overnight thing
it's you can see the the illness you
know take hold and you know what I mean
you
watch the whole thing unfold and that's
one of the reasons it's you know again
what you can't accomplish this in a
two-hour movie and why it's so effective
as a series like this
yeah for sure and Phil knew that because
he had experienced it himself so he knew
what that process could look like and
yeah so so so thankful Phil's a little
taller than Marc and so the only
challenge on set was to give all the
other actors five inch lifts and so John
pocket Chino who's like six foot four
was walking around set at six foot nine
and uh but anyway that's a nice
behind-the-scenes back yes
yes I have a few other questions I want
to ask you about um which whatever
happened to a cotton candy autopsy still
working on it
okay so it's getting almost a decade yes
longer than that I mean I I first gotten
wanted to make cotton candy autopsy in
1991 when I first got the mr. bungle
self-titled debut album and the the
cover art on that album was from cotton
candy autopsy and so I reached out to
those guys not long after and and it's
just you know that's just a giant it's
it's just one of those long I'll make it
before I die and and hopefully soon
sooner rather than later but I've
written a script with my wife Shannon
who's a clown and you know we're really
you know I you know we talked about
horror movies but something else I
really want to do is like I spend more
of my time laughing than I do like being
serious or in dramatic moments in my
life so I'm I'm my wife's a comedian and
so we have been dying to do something
funny and but this is it's a story
really about assimilation
and it's about these these clowns who
are trying to become normal and to
assimilate back into normal society but
it's impossible it's impossible if
you're a clown
you find this this would be a movie or
do you think it's more of a series we'll
see I'm I'm in I'm in I mean yeah I just
literally finished I know this much is
true so that is one of those things
that's been a film forever in my mind
and I'm I'm just I'm right now it's just
open toe so what else it could be
you know so let's we'll see what kind of
life do you think Dane DeHaan went on
went off and led at the end of place
beyond the pines that see that's an that
that's another idea of this open ending
that I you know that I tried to do at
the end of I know this much is true with
Dominic condesa
what happens to them at the end of I
know this much is true
I had my he is what happens to Ryan
Gosling and Michelle Williams when they
separate and walk off into their
separate ways at the end of Blue
Valentine and what happens to Dane at
the end of pines I have my own ideas but
I don't want to say it because if I
would have said it I would have made it
and I want audiences to write their own
endings again that's this is what I try
to think of as a as an audience members
I love having my own imagination in a
movie so there's no it's almost like fan
fiction at that point sure but by the
way I think that and you said it earlier
in this interview but the audience's of
imagination will always be more powerful
than anything you put on screen I agree
it needs the shark in Jaws
I was literally gonna say that it's like
it always gonna be more powerful um yeah
I we talked a while ago and I'm curious
what ever happened to metalhead
metalhead became sound of metal which is
that literally I wanted to ask you that
yes because I saw sound of metal at TIFF
and was like this is metalhead yeah yeah
yeah so I was you know I started making
metal ed from 2007 right my son Cody was
born he's 13 now until a couple months
before I made Blue Valentine and spent a
year two years shooting and editing Blue
Valentine came out of that and I had
place beyond the pines ready to go when
it came out of place beyond the pines I
went back to metalhead which I had been
shooting with this band Jusuf er almost
like a hybrid doc and I realized it
wasn't I wasn't gonna be able to finish
it the way that I had started it I had
just become such a different person and
I needed to but I wanted it to get made
still I thought it was still a valuable
story and so my buddy Darius I was
looking for a film to make and so I put
it up for adoption yeah you know I put
up for adoption and he raised it and I'm
so proud of him for what he has been
able to do with it and it's so nice to
see a film that you know I mean it's one
of the one of the great one of the
things I love about where I'm at in my
life right now is the ability to help
other filmmakers get their visions out
into the world you know I've been you
know there's you know Darius has his
film my wife has been making stuff that
I've been helping her go with his other
you know younger filmmakers that I've
been you know trying to mentor and you
know I'd really like to not only you
know because I'm so slow between my
movies you know the four year four years
between every project yeah something
like that so you know in those times
though I'd love you know and I just know
what it takes for me to make something
so I can help other people get stuff
going if I can have ideas you know I
have a number of ideas and if other
people can take those ideas and run with
them then that's great you know as long
as those ideas you get to be realized
you know cuz that was my biggest fear
with metalhead at one point it's like
his this idea is just gonna turn into
smoke and so I'm thankful Darius adopted
that kid and and and raised it raised it
well yeah I thought he did a really good
job at showing what it was like for some
what you've seen it obviously hmm yes oh
I thought he did a really good job
visualizing what someone was going
through and I thought rizz
great job with this yes yeah yeah yeah
you know what you know one of the first
inspirations for that movie was for me
was Nicolas Philibert did a documentary
about a deaf world deaf community
Nicolas Philibert who made to be in to
have and you know and then I also think
about all those movies I used to watch
the bracket you know brackets movies
like the act of seeing with one's own
eyes and silent movies um and just the
idea of playing with your senses in a
movie was was an idea of losing a sense
you know in in your life and you know me
I'm a drummer so I'm I'm like halfway
gone with with my hearing my tinnitus is
so bad so it's yeah anyway no I I why I
don't want to say too much more about it
really people are gonna see it but have
Gosling and Eva Mendes ever thanked you
for introducing them oh I don't know
about that I don't know what has taken
him I've begged them a bunch for sure
first I'm just [ __ ] with you but you
know two of the most beautiful people I
know and and it was amazing shooting
that movie and seeing seeing them
together you know it was it was like
really really beautiful beautiful
experience and I'm so happy for them you
know and trying to hopefully work with
both of them again someday soon yeah I
would say that you and Ryan together had
been okay alright when are people gonna
be able to watch on streaming or see
brother tide I don't know there's uh no
that's that's that's kind of a scary
proposition that's like the juvenilia
you know maybe I have to be a little
older for that to happen or someone has
to come out and decide that they want to
all those 1950's doo-wops of Christmas
songs that I put in the soundtrack well
my question for you is so you
who owns the rights do you own the
rights to the film yeah okay so
basically it's a question of because of
the soundtrack of polio gosh yeah yeah I
I up the 35-millimeter print in my dad's
basement in Colorado so it's yeah so
it's just a question of there I mean
there's fans of yours that have
obviously never seen the movie and
there's not much footage that is out
there so now you know it's hilarious I
know we'll see we'll see I'm open if
someone ever came out of the woodwork
who wanted to to release that I'd love
to have a conversation with in my love
for you know people to see it it's you
know it's it would be hard for me to
watch it just because it represents a
different era of a similar subject
matter but a different way in which I
was making films at that time my life
you know that was that was I think still
when I was more egocentric as a
filmmaker it was more about me at that
time you know that was when I was in
film school and when I thought that I
was gonna make them you know I heard the
Wild Bunch at 1,600 edits and I thought
that I could make a movie with more
edits than the WoW bunch I mean that was
and so that was like why I made that
movie in a lot of ways was to cut more
than the Wild Bunch and and number
showing it at Sundance in 1998 and
seeing that there was like six people in
the audience and I realized six people
give a [ __ ] about my edits and I started
to realize that why don't I go to why
don't I love movies from the first place
and it was actors and so in all those
years between blue brother tide and Blue
Valentine I learned to I learned what
was always important to me about being a
filmmaker so yeah it's it's it would be
interesting be interesting if someone
wants to release it it'd be awesome yeah
I'm I'm just thinking there's something
if I remember correctly there was a shot
in through like a like a party scene
where like the cameras on a dolly going
through a party I could be wrong about
this yeah right okay so I'm not I'm not
mistaken on this but I remember that
shot being like oh [ __ ] that is a cool
shot yeah you know it was a lot of shots
we were doing like 70 setups a day on
that I was the DP we had dolly tracks
all over the place we had like a little
you know 12 person crew of all of our
friends at the film school and we were
just living it making a family making a
movie and it was you know it took like
four and a half years to put it together
and yeah it's a it represents a certain
time I think I would probably ready
people seeing it if if someone wanted to
pony up you know I'm just throwing this
out there because one of the we have a
lot of people that work at Collider and
I asked people for questions and
something that people wanted to know was
HBO is getting ready to do you know
their series or their limited series of
parasite and so the question is of
course if they asked you to do an
episode would you be willing all depends
on availability and time and what I'm
doing you know
I mean I obviously sign this deal with
HBO so I'm I love working with them and
I have my own project so I'm gonna be
you know bringing to them and we'll see
what what happens with those um yeah I
never say I never say never it's the
difficult thing about jumping into a
show that's already like a perfect movie
you know like I don't know I don't know
what when necessarily I would add to it
I I always feel strange about making
other people's movies because I feel
like every every filmmaker they make
their own choices and I I love to see
the choices they make and I and I don't
I couldn't make their same choices but I
couldn't I wouldn't want to change any
filmmakers choice that they ever make it
either you know I got it I do um I think
that bong has talked about how there was
a lot of stuff that he wrote that
obviously didn't make the movie and so
it'll be interesting to see you know
he's very supportive of doing this
series yeah well sure I'm sure you know
it's you know but what this is my
basically my last thing for you because
we taught for 17 hours but yeah I am
curious do you have a lot of scripts in
the desk that you want to make do you
have things that are sort of ready to go
or do you sort of and also like
obviously you signed the deal with HBO
you can do stuff but like you just
worked your ass off for the last few
years is it sort of like I need months
to like decompress even the things that
I have in my desk and yeah I do have a
number of scripts I have cotton candy
you have empire of the summer moon
I have muscle I have a lot of I have
other original projects that I've been
working on but even if I was to do one
of those projects that the script is
already written and I've already you
know empire of the summer moon written
30 drafts on it I have to start over
again because I'm a different person now
than I was before I started you know
before I started I know this much is
true and when I go into it again new
it's gonna change and I have to kind of
start all over again so but at the same
time I'm in the place now where I need
to you know I make movies about family
and so I've been trying to just be with
my my family and you know I can't be
hypocritical I make movies about family
I my inspiration comes from being a
father and a son and so you had to use
the metaphor like I feel like the well
is pretty dry and so I needed to I
needed to rain a lot of people watching
this and just I think they don't realize
the amount of time it takes to actually
make a project what it takes to film
what it takes to edit and what
sacrifices you have to make in your
personal life to actually accomplish
putting something like this on the
screen yeah I mean it's fun it's my up
until Oh two weeks ago it was seven days
a week 12 hours a day for 12 hours day
minimum for the last two and a half
years and it was a
singing every moment every moment I felt
like I was on vacation so now is
actually now that I'm done with it now I
have to go back to work and I have to
figure out what I'm gonna do again right
now now the work starts and it is it's a
lot and it's relentless but it's a
blessing because this is you know this
is this is like my dream since I was
since I can remember dreaming was that I
would make movies or you know to tell
stories on film you know TV shows
whatever and so I take every moment and
every chance I get in every opportunity
I get I don't I take it as a real
blessing and and a joy yeah look I'm
super happy you made something with HBO
or some deal because you know I want you
making more projects and yeah we you are
what we call a talented filmmaker so
Russian Steve Zaillian don't rush me
right it will be faster than four years
but I also understand that I gotta spend
time with your family and stuff you know
I mean like my oldest son 16 years old
so that that happens quick man
yeah I don't know what that's about but
I get what you're saying on that note
I'm just gonna say thank you so much for
talking with me for 17 hours and please
pass on your family but I said thank you
yes really
imma go get the chicken off the grill
now right exactly and listen man again
congrats on the series a good to see you
again
yeah nice to see you in cyberspace yes
right next time next time face to face
okay when the world comes back to
something